well iran is stepping up cooperation
with the world's nuclear watchdog having
imposed restrictions on inspectors since
february the international atomic energy
agency will now be allowed to install
new memory cards at key atomic sites and
be able to continue filming the
announcement comes after what's been
described as constructive talks with the
agency's head raphael grossi he's been
on his first visit to tehran since
ibrahim raisi became president last
month while these talks are coming as
well powers try to salvage the iran
nuclear deal iran signed that agreement
back in 2015. it was designed to limit
tehran's nuclear ambitions in exchange
for sanctions relief but then in may
2018 then president donald trump
withdrew the u.s and began reimposing
sanctions on iran
in november 2020 the iaea reported that
iran's stockpile of enriched uranium had
reached 12 times permitted levels and
the organization says iran has limited
access to its nuclear sites now since
february
well earlier this month iran's new
president said his country is ready to
revive talks on the 2015 nuclear deal
but not under western pressure
i've said previously that we will
definitely have negotiations in our
order of business but not with the
pressure that the other parties are
pursuing this pressure has failed before
the americans and europeans have
experienced multiple times that these
negotiations along with pressure do not
work what we are pursuing in these talks
is the lifting of the cruel sanctions
well israel's prime minister has called
on wild powers to keep iran from
obtaining nuclear weapons naftali
bennett wants a time limit on
international negotiations
i'm calling on world powers don't fall
into the trap of iranian deception that
will lead to additional concessions
you must not give up on inspecting sites
and the most important thing the most
important message is that there must be
a time limit the iranians are dragging
on we must set a clear deadline that
says up until here
well for its part saudi arabia says it
still has doubts about iran's nuclear
programme and warns that future
agreements must be sustainable
we have been clear and said that we have
doubts about the nuclear deal with iran
and we feel that there are not enough
inspections we want there to be an
agreement on the iran nuclear issue
existing agreements have many flaws iran
must respond more positively and there
must be sustainable agreements we stress
that iran's nuclear program must remain
peaceful and there must also be a sense
of reassurance on these doubts as well
as threats that iran may pose
well let's bring in mark fitzpatrick he
is a former deputy assistant secretary
of state and an associate fellow with
the international institute of strategic
studies he joins us now from washington
dc
mark there was a suggestion that rossi
had been offering to visit iran since
the election but that the iranians
weren't keen i believe the russians were
involved in brokering today's visit so
why now
the iranians were playing brinksmanship
they resisted
giving in to the iaea request until the
very last minute
the very last minute being today's
sunday because monday the board of
governors of the iaea will meet and had
there not been an agreement to service
these cameras and to replace the memory
chips
then the iaea board would have voted on
a uh a resolution uh censoring uh iran
and that would have uh led to iran uh in
a huff uh not agreeing to go back into
talks so this was this was very
important that grossi was able to
achieve this today it really was the
last minute sure well mark i recall when
you were in vienna you were i believe in
charge of liaison with the iaea this nod
that we're seeing now to cooperation
from tehran is it enough do you think to
as a step to avoid censure for iran at
that meeting next week
oh yes it's it's enough to avoid censure
it doesn't do anything else hardly i
mean it just it averts a crisis that's
the big step today it averts a crisis it
doesn't solve anything because uh the
issues are all still ongoing and as you
mentioned uh russia was involved in this
arrangement so was the united states
actually all the parties to the jcpoa uh
worked together behind the scenes to
arrange for gosi to be able to get to
vienna
well just to be clear about what's
happened
the iaea is going to be able to switch
out its memory cards but is it actually
going to be allowed to take home footage
is there still some contention about
that
oh i think you're right about that i
think it's just that they're going to be
able to replace the memory cards and
service the equipment make sure it's all
working
i don't think they will be able to take
back uh the the old memory cards
but i want to make one other thing clear
because it's often misunderstood iran
still has access
to the enrichment hall and other nuclear
facilities in iran it just doesn't have
access to these cameras at sites that
were additionally part of verification
under the jcpoa
right well given that so many different
signatories to the jcpoa have been
involved in trying to make sure that
this didn't happen i want to take stock
of where the talks are we've obviously
got a new hard-line iranian president
since negotiation stalled back in june
and now a u.s president who's also
dealing with the fallout from
afghanistan and having to find a new
approach to tehran's new administration
where do you actually see this going
you know the talks that were going on in
in the spring could have been um settled
at any time if iran's supreme leader ali
ayatollah ali khamenei
was willing to make a compromise he
wasn't
uh and then the talks were suspended um
to wait for iran's uh presidential
election in june
and then to everybody's surprise iran
hasn't gone back until uh still now and
maybe another few weeks before it goes
back and the big question is will the
supreme leader make the compromises that
are necessary to make a deal for example
he says that
all of the u.s sanctions imposed under
donald trump must be lifted
the united states is willing to lift all
the sanctions that would impede
implementation of the jcpoa
but not things that are extraneous like
sanctions on human rights totally
relevant there are a couple of other
sticking points i think they you know
they can be negotiated if there is a
willingness uh to be flexible and i
haven't seen that willingness yet on
iran's part we'll have to see how that
goes in the coming
weeks and months mark fitzpatrick there
a former deputy assistant secretary of
state um speaking to us from washington
d.c great to get you on al jazeera mark
thank you for joining us
happy to talk with you thank you